Jason "Wee Man" Acuña might be the most
recognizable member of the "Jackass" cast,
but this skateboarder's got some tricks you
haven't seen – and some tacos you have to try.
Jason Acuña's father George served in the United
States Army and was stationed in Germany when he
met and married Acuña's mother. The couple was
transferred to a base in Pisa, Italy, while his
mother was pregnant. Though English is his first
language, Acuña's mother taught him German as a
boy, and he remains fluent in the language. He
told Steve-O on the Steve-O Wild Ride Podcast,
"You know when you're a kid, and
you’re asking your mom, 'What's this?'
My mom would tell me in German, and I'd
be like, 'No, not that funny language!'"
Eventually, Acuña would settle in southern
California, where his father's family is from,
and as a preteen, he became heavily involved
in the area's skateboarding culture.
When he was born, the delivering doctor noticed
that Jason Acuña's head was large compared to the
rest of his body. Concerned that the baby might be
hydrocephalic, the doctor ran tests and determined
that Acuña instead had a genetic condition
known as achondroplasia, which causes dwarfism.
As a boy, Acuña's mother took him to
an annual conference sponsored by the
support group Little People of America,
thinking that he might enjoy meeting other
children with dwarfism. Acuña felt differently,
however, telling The New York Times in 2022,
"I came back and I go, 'Mom, I don't
want to go to these things anymore.'
I'm like, 'That's not what my life is about."
He compared the impulse to group
people with dwarfism together to
the idea that a bald man should
be friends with other bald men.
"He's a dude, he's a jogger, he wants to
hang out with other joggers. Skateboarder,
hang out with skateboarders."
As a young skateboarder in Torrance, California,
in the late 1980s and early 1990s, Jason Acuña
began attracting attention. In his interview with
The New York Times, he said he was already being
sponsored by local skate shops at age 14. At the
time, the local Torrance skateboard company was
World Industries, and Acuña and his friends
would try to score free merchandise at the
company warehouse. Opened in 1987 by professional
skateboarders Steve Rocco and Rodney Mullen,
World Industries billed itself as the first
skateboard company operated by and for skaters.
The story goes that Steve Rocco's
brother Sal gave Acuña his nickname,
shouting "Hey everyone! Wee Man is
here!" whenever Acuña would come around.
A few years later, World Industries'
magazine Big Brother published a photo
spread featuring Acuña and printed the nickname.
After that, Wee Man was his official stage name.
Much of the groundwork for what
would one day become "Jackass"
was laid at Big Brother magazine, the
publishing arm of World Industries.
Started by Steve Rocco in 1992, the magazine
embraced its parent company's "for us, by us"
ethos and ran skateboarding interviews and
photo spreads alongside features and humor
pieces that were unpolished, irreverent,
and raunchy. In other words, it was…
"'Jackass' before 'Jackass.'"
Acuña got a job in the office by virtue
of being local and hanging around so much
that editor and future "Jackass" director
Jeff Tremaine finally just put him to work.
When Big Brother released its
first video — a skateboarding
compilation — Acuña appeared on
the box art covered in blue paint.
There is an egalitarian streak that runs
through the two-plus decade run of "Jackass."
Everyone suffers on camera at some point,
and everyone is the butt of the joke.
Over the years, many of Acuña's
stunts and pranks have been no
different from the ones performed by
Knoxville or the rest of the cast.
But many of his best and most memorable
stunts came from the unique opportunities
afforded by his height. Acuña was often
paired with cast member Preston Lacy,
as their two polar-opposite body types
complement one another to comedic effect.
Because of his stature, Jason Acuña
is the most recognized "Jackass"
cast member — even more so than Knoxville.
His fame is inescapable, and he estimates that
he's been recognized on the street nearly every
day since the show premiered in the year 2000.
Over the years, Acuña has avoided the tabloid
attention that some of his castmates have faced.
In fact, he has discovered that the name "Wee
Man" serves a useful role in delineating those
people who want to be his friend from
those who simply want proximity to fame.
Speaking to Jenkem Magazine about
romantic relationships, Acuña said,
"No chick has ever called me Wee Man that
I've dated. I've also never dated a chick
that I noticed would call me Wee Man because
it didn't feel like she was trying to date me."
So if he's not wasting it on the spoils of
fame, what does Jason Acuña do with his money?
In 2008, he became an investor in the
California-based Mexican restaurant
chain Chronic Tacos, opening a franchise in
Redondo Beach called "Wee Man's Chronic Tacos."
The chain was a good fit for him, not just because
of the rock and roll street art aesthetic of its
locations, but also as a connection to his
father's family, which is of Mexican descent.
In 2012, Jason Acuña took a rare leading man
role in the family Christmas comedy "Elf-Man."
When a little girl makes a wish on an old elf
doll to bring her father home on Christmas Eve, a
magical elf, played by Acuña, appears to make the
wish come true by morning, when Santa will bring
him back to the North Pole. Little do they know
that the little girl's father has been kidnapped
by a group of thieves seeking his fantastic new
invention. When the thieves attack the house, the
elf must defend the family by believing in himself
and becoming the Christmas superhero Elf-Man.
The film was released direct to video and was not
terribly well-received. The most positive review
might be this YouTube video featuring the children
of Acuña's "Jackass" castmate Dave England.
"I thought it was really funny that
the robbers were not very smart.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about 'Jackass'
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.